hey what's up my name is Samuel
eight-armed a property investor and this
is Q&A Sunday here it's gonna happen
either the video last week a property
video and got loads of amazing questions
so I'm going to be answering all of your
property related niggling burning
questions here's the cool part though if
you comment your questions below next
week at 7:00 p.m. on Sunday I'm going to
do a new video where I'm going to be
answering all of the questions as many
as I can from the comments in this video
so let's see what we got from last week
some great questions Ben verge 8
question once you get money from an
angel investor how do you manage to find
the military pay them with interest on
top so you get 50 grand from angels over
4 years and you invest that amount in 25
percent ROI deals yes you'd have the
money after 4 years but it means never
touching it and doesn't even cover their
interests on top listen if you borrow 20
grand from an investor and then you put
that 20 grand to work and you say to the
investor I'll pay you back in five years
and every year I'll pay you 10 percent
on your money here's what you don't pay
them a 10 percent of course out of the
cash flow course how do you pay them the
at the end of the five years or 20 grand
there's a few different options you
could if you want to be really safe you
could all of the profit from the deal
you could put aside all of it and save
it up to pay them back and that way
you're not going to make a penny for
five years but at least you're going to
know about depending back or you could
refinance the house after five years or
you could get the money from other
sources so that there's not one answer
but you just need to make sure that the
property deal is profitable enough in
itself to be able to pay them back so
that's my answer
I hope that helps guys I know this is
icy 16 hi Samuel can you help me I want
to get a development fund for a meaty
project but the seller won't agree to a
conditional offer whilst the planning
goes through are there any other options
please if you're buying a piece of land
or you're going to do a development
project and the seller you're wanting to
say I want to get the planning first
before I this it sounds to me like the
seller has a feeling that the planning
will not come through potentially so so
if they won't agree to a conditional
offer
subject to planning I wouldn't buy it
but I would find another piece of land
or unset okay then
in that case I'll pay a price
that is reflective to there being no
plan permission which is probably going
to be like a tenth of what you're
offering right now so which ones are
going to bet I can pay you this amount
which is what you want that is going to
be subject to planning or I can pay you
this amount which is assuming that I
won't be able to get planning or I can't
give you a small deposit and then I'll
get the planning and I'll pay you the
rest when I've got the planning and if
the plan doesn't come through you keep
the deposit but obviously don't put down
what tens and tens of thousands maybe
ten grands or I won't pay you anything
now and I'll do the project and I'll
give you a slice of the profit plus the
money for the land like there's so many
options when you're doing development
it's just a case of working with the
seller but if the sellers being really
difficult and you can't make the figure
stack you may have to walk away when
you're doing deals the best advice I'll
give you is always be prepared to walk
okay what else we got
i samuel always give you forty videos
thank you my friend i've said 20 grand
cash over a long period of time it is
long it takes a long time for most
people to say for any grounds to wall
run after a lot of convincing from your
videos i'm prepared to invest it into
property currently almost at home mom
and recently started educate myself on
property and plan to attend a few free
courses what strategy would you suggest
I use it to invest this money wisely and
to get a quick return cash flow thanks
for the advice listen you've got a few
different options you could invest the
20 grand on one little property like a
single a house it's going to give you a
little income awesome what we do if
you're going to do that the problem is
it's only gonna give you a small income
and then you're gonna have to wait ages
to get another 20 grand
so you either invest the 20 grams
document it and have it as a case today
and then the next 20 grand don't work so
hard raise the money and then you can
say look this is what I did here I want
to do it again but I want you to put the
money in will go 50/50 on the profits
like it's or listen most people work so
hard to save money and then they then
build up their property portfolio so
slowly I mean what what I did when I was
starting out I didn't have quite 20 was
let it was less but I put it into my
education and you might be what if
that's 20 grand into my education but I
could buy a house of that but you are a
better investment
houses and if you invest into property
it's a slow game whether you invested
into that into education similarly
you're better to get that 21 fast so
there's different options but what I'll
say is good for you and I think you're
on the right track just make sure if you
do invest that 20 grand into a small
single house document in because you're
not what I want to work hard to get
another 21 you're going to do something
different always it'll be forever before
you financially for you want to do in
twelve months
okay reality escape hi Samuel how do I
learn more about the paperwork and
regulations for the property sector okay
we wrote a book on this if you go onto
Amazon and search Samuel Leeds it's a
bucket it's compliance made easy check
out the book
dr kim hye-sung another great video
thank you I've just secured another
property deal after your crash course oh
wow during the course man you just start
getting deals and this time it's a city
center studio apartment and I'm getting
a lot of interest from potential tenants
who are on housing benefits although I
don't s criminate and would like to help
these people get a smart move from the
business point of view what are the
positives and negatives many thanks in
advance okay um listen benefit tenants
are not bad tenants this is Sarah Lake
however you've got to be true to what
the business plan is so I personally I
don't buy properties usually with
benefit tenants in mind sometimes I do I
have bought properties solely for that
purpose but if you've bought these city
certainly apartment so you've got these
studios and the plan is professional
tenants and perfect it's not
discriminating it's just that that's
your business market so in the same way
if you've got HMO there's a professional
hiker moment you had students that
wanted to move in you could say look
this is not a student household this is
a professional house share so it's not
discriminating and legally and ethically
I don't think that you you know you've
got anything to worry about at all
because that's the business strategy
that's your market but it's great to see
and hear that you've got a heart to help
you know help people that maybe are
struggling what I would probably suggest
is make a lot of money as much as you
can at true to your business strategy
and then put a particular the profits
put a percentage towards you know
helping the homeless or give him back
and that way you've got your business
which is making money and helping people
because you're given accommodation and
then because if you try and if you feel
sorry of people you think I'll go on and
you live with someone in and and
and then it's like it just it just you
might end up not making money and then
you can't you can't help anybody so I
would say be true to your vision of
being a professional and if you want
professional tournaments have
professional tenants sometimes are there
situations where I've had a professional
tenant that then loses their job and
then they simply need to become a
benefit oh and I'm gonna kick you out
now you want to be gracious but be true
to your market and do what you need to
do to make money
that's what I would say good job my man
I think you're a great person and I hope
to meet you as well and if you boil all
these properties after the crash course
you should come on windows website drop
us a message go to winners on a
Wednesday com fill out form I'd love to
get to meet you okay Lewis Clark I know
Lewis Clark something on 15 you and the
dude who saved up 10 grand from paper
ads I remember you from the previous
videos I'm 58 and I'm starting to learn
about investing money good what are the
pros and cons of property investment
compared to stock market investing I
can't decide which one's better
listen stock is okay if you do it
properly stock markets fine but the
thing I like about property is its
bricks and mortar
you know it's bricks and mortar and you
get paid rent so it's not just a case of
a buy a stock and I hope for it to go up
and you can leave with your money if
you're investing in the stock market you
can't get a mortgage on stocks so if
you've got twenty grounds you can buy 20
grounds worth of stocks whereas if
you're doing property you've got 20
rounds you might be able to get 80 grand
or a hundred grand hats with it because
it's leverage so you're gonna make more
money in property if you do it right
that's my opinion but then I'm a
property guy so I would stick with
property if I get alright last one last
one
Ryan Anderson as a biblical economist do
you believe Lease Option agreements are
equitable like I think what he's trying
to say is as a Christian or lease option
agreements like fair are they Ithaca I
think that's your point because I
studied biblically economics at barbel
college yeah completely when I'm talking
to sellers and I'm offering Lease Option
agreements that's always the last option
firstly I'll always give them an offer
I'll advise them as if there are a
family member I'll tell them to hold on
and rent out themselves but if they're
stuck and they've got no money and they
want rid of the property then a lease
option agreement is a good solution for
some people of course it's good for me
as the buyer but it sometimes is a very
good solution and also I never do lease
option agreement without
the seller represented by a solicitor
and the solicitors job is always to make
sure that it's fair because if it's not
if you screw someone over and then it
ends up going to court the judge is
going to look and it's going to be like
oof
you know this person was taken advantage
of so if you do fare and you have a
solicitor that represents the seller
right from the beginning it protects you
it means you can sleep at night you
don't need to be unethical so make a lot
of money okay so make a lot of money you
need to add a lot of value and you to
help a lot of people money follows value
so yeah I think they're completely
ethical and I'm very happily talk to any
of my sellers then I've done a lease
option agreement with I'm very happily
have them in the studio talk to about
the situation because you know I hand on
heart think that I'm helping sellers and
that's however my business hope you
found that video useful I hope you
learned a lot don't forget to comment
your questions below also if you enjoyed
the video smash the like button show
some support and subscribe to turn the
notification bells on if you want to
come to the property investors crash
course if use a two-day property program
it's very good he's a very good program
and you're gonna have your mind blown
and so many doors are gonna open for you
at the crash course you can get your
free ticket on the house there's a
one-pound booking fee you can get your
free ticket right over here don't forget
to subscribe as well over here thanks so
much
book on the crash course subscribe I see
you next time
[Music]